[Applaudissements]
les amis on avait cloué au lit
les amis que maintenant ça fait qu'on
s'est pas vu ouais ou en vidéo un an et
deux mois
quoi qu'elle moi quelle moisson précis
j'apprécie le temps 2010 est ici et
c'était passé ça c'est ridicule on
commence par huit premiers mois cubilot
cubilot dans des bars on se dit qu on
fait du rap avec n'importe quel moment
je peux dire un truc que j'avoue
papouasie au delà du fait que je veux
dire les justes parce que je n'ai même
pas
[Musique]
alors non flou n'est pas mis au fait de
belle et bum le reste de sa vie mais
c'est vraiment pour cacher quelque chose
ma cuisine quand l'exercice super
plaisir 6 mai après repris lé là je me
suis souvenu a pas longtemps de quelque
chose c'est qu'on avait fait une petite
ou trop dans une de mes vidéos à
s'allier j'adore ces réactions crois que
c'était genre mi 2015
attention un extrait maintenant non tu
crois que la regardent ensemble je peux
pour la station
on avait fait quoi d'ailleurs ce qu'on
peut faire un bisou à clément souplet
les oncles et moment sur la famille on
est ensemble vraiment dans le match que
ce montage pour clément s'il te plaît tu
me mets deux dauphins qui passe
discrètement dans la vie
est-ce que vous êtes prêts c'est parti
et mon allégeance ou du report de sa
vidéo geste à l'appui
j'avais la voix cassée je vais l'avocat
s'est fait longtemps que j'ai pas budget
de toi comment tu as pu devenir celle là
maintenant on regarde ça on rigole mais
d'accord pourquoi à l'époque personne ne
dit rien parce que parce que là
peut-être qu'on va rire de nous plus
tard parce qu'on est oui alors moi ça
les gens évoluent les gars du tout celle
là c'est la vidéo pour le flot du futur
te manque pas de moi frère je suis très
de hausse et rôle à temps je fais la
même elle car c'est bon là déjà les
vidéos je vais arriver le truc mais n'a
fait déjà plein dans trois ans tu passe
à autre chose
et au lit je sais pas si je serai encore
en vie tant des bisous et j'espère
tellement de confiance les cheveux dolly
on vous a pas oubliés je vous le dis
vous avez été la longueur un papillon
ici et mon allégeance il ya pas de cette
vidéo gsh a le plus bio ok you're
typique frigoli d'albums et là on a visé
haut ont démarché squeeze on fout le
bordel dans ta vidéo comme les cas on
peut rater nos âmes trop faire le beau
devant l'ordi avoir la dalle comme jumbo
[Applaudissements]
peut le faire aussi
je regarde y'a rien tout le monde c'est
big flo et oli alors aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur un super jeu on va le
tester ensemble avec jumbo petit
bonhomme là et ça nous a peut-être de
zombies quoi mais les gains au décalage
au système en même temps la donne tu
sais quoi
jab sont que c'était en 2008 écoute
bercé ya trois ans c'est tous derrière
moi rien à voir avec moi gros big up à
tous les ringards de france c'était bien
quand même
alors c'est vrai que du coup on la
préfère en effet un tweet en 2015
ensemble et c'est je suis ému parce
qu'on a grandi
chacun a vécu vous êtes vous dans le
lamih le music game one en mémoire du
game moi je te le dis ce quiz on est
fier de ce que de l'arrêter de l'onu
mais tout est ce que tu as accompli je
trouve que tu vises sainement
ces milieux à l'est des philippines fini
vous avez compris aujourd'hui c'est le
troisième jamais deux sans trois comme
on dit c'est le troisième et dernier
épisode avec ce concept là mais cette
fois tu as je me dirai pas ce que tu
veux dire c'est le 3ème et le dr on
arrive nico les amis on va mettre une
vidéo de nikos aliagas qui dit
christelle du dico les gens vont être
déçus maintenant dans trois secondes
comme jusqu'à 3 1 2 3 il n'y a pas à
l'arrêt dans cette vidéo parce qu'on l'a
laissé tranquille et nous a tout
enseigner nous a tout appris il a pris
du temps pour nous il a vraiment
d'autres choses à faire mais on vole
dans nos propres exactement mais les
jambes comme nous aider à brno propose
maintenant on va prendre démodé de
twitter c'est par les mots du dico c'est
ce que j'allais bien c'est exactement ce
qu'il allait dire il y avait les bleus
voilà la vidéo ni les gens nous ont
envoyé plein de mots avec mon action sur
twitter sur le hashtag des mots pour
squeeze je voulais ma démo pour squeeze
big flo et oli mais on en verra répond
c'est beaucoup trop long on est
énormément de réponses presque 4000
réponse les gars désolé qu'on va devoir
faire une musique et calais des mots
dans nos couples et je vais imposer au
lit des mots il va m'en imposer aux
maires imposable si vous tombez sur pour
la première fois son corps son ce
concept vous vivez dans une grotte quoi
les mecs esclave besoin de ça pour faire
une musique n'en attend pas sortir sont
pas autre chose on a besoin d'un café
pour faire une croix palo est ce qu'on
aurait peut-être peuvent de 9 ie noël
on a mangé libanais juste avant de dire
que l'air est très pure aujourd'hui dans
ce studio au pays ne veut que péter et
rod et c'est entièrement faux géré tout
une et empêche tout faire goûter au tout
une fois un p vas-y non ceux qui ont
l'oreille absolue commenté la menthe
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
c'est ça ces soldats à faire soleil mon
dieu qui sait faire ça j'ai pensé à une
mélodie hier comme je te dis qu'ils
feraient la chose suivante vous moquez
pas les gars comme tintin tintin
nombreuses et un tintin tintin tintin
tintin
j'ai l'impression qu'ils nous sommes
toujours la même chose le talent un papa
maintint tin tin tin tin tin tam art et
que j'entraînais tintin tintin tintin la
la la la la la la
[Musique]
je sais pas je vis date est un
groupement d oie pardon désolé que rush
très heureux de vous retrouver à l'or
olympique tu te fout ouvertement de ma
gueule en vidéo quoi pas du tout les
gars est ce que je suis un fantôme
c'est vrai mais je suis fatigué les
gardes à la mélodie principale
j'aimerais bien a doublé avec une autre
piste pour qu'elle soit un peu plus de
puissance je dois relais l'audi qui se
souviennent comme fera gl et non ma tête
elle ne m'a jamais je vais proposer une
petite nouvelle mélodie du coup pour
gimp est la principale
non non vraiment nom est 3ème étape la
basse le bit
j'ai tout faux j'aime les beats simple
pas de blague pas de commentaires c'est
ok aucun commentaire
[Musique]
je suis qu'avec je suis un fantôme dans
cette vidéo jamais si tu fais ça plus
l'étape d'avant et oui c'est là où ça
devient exergue le musée qu'est ce que
tu attends pause tu peux pas me rajouter
des petites chez parce que tu allais
dire mais tu veux pas moi je fais des
petites trompettes hashtag stromae un
peu à l'as roma attendait un bond à
étapes trois improvisé en se laissant
guider sur la vibe du morceau j'ai un
petit truc et ça va être une simple
touche j'ai rajouté deux petits trucs
voilà c'est ça le vrai nom à temps après
on apprend projets achevés d'improviser
cette fois c'était la dernière
tu peux croire que c'est qu'une crise
rien jamais en france quelque chose a
sonné aussi malade que prochaine étape
la basse là bas c'est vrai que ça manque
de basses est mon seul argument après si
vous écoutez pas la vidéo avec des
écouteurs si vous l'écoutez comme ça
vous l'entendrez pas parce que cdm fera
céder son que les ordis sortent pas
c'est vrai en plus donc là si vous
entendez pas très bien mais qu'il est au
lit je suis tellement le fantôme dans
cette vidéo tout le monde s'en fout de
moi dans le groupe big flo lit dans les
vidéos free ça du dico qu'ils ont même
pas remarqué que j'étais pas là
choisissez bon continue on en est où là
la base qu'elle basse soit tu je veux
une basse qui est de la présence est ce
que bouchez vous les oreilles et on va
voir si ça fait tomber des trucs
derrière
où
non mais je sais pourquoi je pense qu'il
faut qu'ils aient tous qu est la bonne
c'est le morceau en lui-même qui est
puissant qui va tout faire tomber parce
qu'une base sans ses frères et soeurs
elle ne fait rien car l'égoïsme est
aujourd'hui au coeur de la société et
pourtant on n'a jamais eu autant besoin
d'être solidaires tête une idée aux pour
nous tirer chacun les arts les autres
vers le haut nous élever tous ensemble
pourquoi ne pas c'est bon les amis les
revenus je crois qu'on doit tout écouter
tout l'instructeur ensemble avec moi ça
fait tout ensemble mais moi tout
maintien du goal de france sont les
parties
[Musique]
pas tout de suite tout de suite les amis
y'a quoi après la prod les paroles
musique question un cadeau pour noël que
tu crées par pur hasard l'a peut-être eu
des rabbins de la gym c'est bien mais il
est un bon album en plus alors il ya
plein de potes youtube etc nous ont
répondu on va prendre quelques uns mais
il faut aussi faire participer mais bien
sûr est communauté on profane sur
youtube heures et deux tiers
genre ok c'est bon qu'ils nous proposent
callipyge qui a de belles fesses
harmonieusement avons dit c'est génial
quand femmes callipyges les danseurs
sont sûrs d'eux-mêmes vigoureux
callipyge on se connaissait pas du tout
flou qu'elle parlait walo flou c'est
qu'à l'image est bien plus décalé pedro
cabourg foodingues brut bourrin sa place
le dialecte du sud ça vient du sud comme
vous et moi je veux bien que ben tu le
veux bien kaboré à cabourg ok tu dis
kaboul on se fait son petit marché des
mots quoi superfétatoire qui s'ajoute
inutilement à une chose utile comme ce
mot à valence à holly la scène politique
française car c'est un joueur pour le
clergé kaboré super bien on connaît un
peu trop incertain waouh celui là mais
il est impossible à placer cheminots
pentax au fil collectionneurs de cordes
destiné à la 39e français des couilles
mais aux morts individus se distingue
d'abord par sa musculature ça c'est
pourtant ce que
ces huit races et j'en ai marre il faut
que tu dis je suis pâmé aux morts pour
un truc comme ça quoi pourquoi non je
dis ça c'est pas ça fait penser à
métamorphose c'est à dire notamment fait
apparaître sur ta peut-être là je sais
que tu vas aimer bismuth non métalliques
dans les cristaux mal à 10 minutes c'est
joli en plus un business en but je vois
bien le dire ok est ce que tu peux rémy
thema voit maintenant il mute anadyomène
sortie mais bien ça j'aime bien sûr j
vers le haut sortie des eaux c'est à
dire sorti des flots à howard ces sommes
donc assez simple il faut trouver un
truc qui sort en h le hc presque schlak
j'ai envie de tentant de le dire se
mouche l'ohio si c'est à dire du mal de
sa propre personne l'objectif
interlocuteur qui diffusera les propos
tenus au cesti les hommes quand je dis
je suis un fantôme au conseil communal
et au classement oui ça j'aime bien
daguerréotype procédés primitifs de la
photographie par lequel images étaient
fixés sur laquelle j'aime bien moi tu
veux ça ou je prends moisi prend pour
toi daguerréotype daguerréotype invite
[ __ ] c'est dur pour toi
we had you for i absence d'intérêt pour
tout ce qui se passe ok des tentes ont
des fauries je suis dans mon adia faurie
foutriquet personnes chétif de petite
taille personnes insignifiante art
foutriquet mec c'est rigolo
moi j'aime bien le prend en tout et vous
tu sais quoi prendre tous les maux du
halal avec toi mais pour votre cuisine
non non aux normes jublot t émergé d'un
rêve sans savoir la faim et envie d'y
retourner pour reconnaître les sons
le dona flor complicité dans ce moment
de la vidéo comme celui-là je la gère
près j'en ai parlé au lille
hexakosioihexekontahexaphobe buteur du
nombre si si si ça existe et je le
prends et je porte mes couilles et je le
mettrais dans le christ est impossible
tu sais même pas comment le prononce ici
hexakosioihexekontahexaphobe et je vais
y arriver je m'entraînerai mascaret
j'aimais bien moi ce carré pro but d'un
certain estuaire par la rencontre du
flux et du reflux attendu lui et que
dans les vagues tu as eu des trucs à
base de rom ou les flots le montant est
pétri shore on dirait un pokémon bonheur
particulière habituellement agréable que
prend la terre après la roja tandja
vient la péta j'adore moi aussi mais tu
le prends ce quiz c'est ta vidéo
attends tu prends mais tu prends fine il
s'est nourri connu une chute est la plus
commune des anomalies innées du
métabolisme elle est caractérisée par un
déficit mental léger à sévères chez les
patients non traités
j'ai pas forcément compris même les
années ça va juste rendu triste en tout
cas mais je pense qu'il vaut mieux pas
avoir fois que je prends un grand chef
anton peu prolixe en gros c'est quand
quelqu'un écrit trop gros et que ça
devient saoulant pas agréable à lire
mais arrête ça existe vraiment ça mais
c'est pas que les cris trop gros trop
longs diffus en parlant c'est pas mal ça
comme cette vidéo c'est cette vidéo elle
est un peu prolixe elle est prolixe
cette vidéo allait produire à prendre
chalumeau pontacq zoophilie collection
de pendule à coucou suisse voudrait
qu'on vende ya pas vraiment de pendule à
coucou suisse
je le prends je le prends la pendule à
couple 6 mai question je dise est à fait
courrier messager chargé d'une dépêche
assez bien onesta fait un et staff et
moi est une sorte de message et de
guerre voilà 30 substances ciation
changement du pain et du vin la
substance du corps de prix de prendre le
prends ça tu vas prendre celui d'après
inexpugnable qu'on ne peut prendre
d'assaut à j'aime bien voir ça tue la
gelée déjà entendu inexpugnable c'est
pour toi amphigourique confus
embrouiller incompréhensible je trouve
qu'il voit très bien en bourrique chorus
ans qui brille intensément c'est bien ça
coruscant et avait six mois je le prends
soin et top twin autorise ce genre est
un dinosaure théropode de la famille des
terrines aux rideaux aux hôtes est dans
la merde
l'an dernier pour toi de la même manière
à ce qu'on dit stop
l'omec non je suis tombé sur calvitie
frère je viens deux je suis flou depuis
le délice de la vixiège calvitie toi
ah ouais et pourquoi mon crâne on dirait
un iphone disent regarde bien iphone
disent les gens m'ont dit ça mec
les gens m'ont dit ça ils n'ont pas
peser le poids de leur mobile oui nous
avons tous nos morts nous sommes prêts
pour faire le clip
alors attention petite particularité
j'aimerais qu'on prenne 48 ou 72 heures
cette fois pour le faire c'est pas non
plus un délai incroyable pour faire un
clip mais c'est un peu plus qu'à des
rares fois ça permettra de faire quelque
chose de mieux oui s'en fout du délai
pour que je puisse dormir aussi ashton
je suis un fantôme
ouais c'est de faire un truc à la bonne
franquette on va plus se travaille et on
va essayer de faire honneur à tous ce
délai la hauteur dans l'arrêt et des
mots du dico etc
sachez que j'ai adoré faire cette série
vidéo avec vous que la prochaine fois
qu'on ferait plutôt comme ça sur la
chaîne cessera je suis ému lothodé
lehrer c'est la fin les gars c'est la
dernière mais est-ce que la fin n'est
pas le début d'autre chose
les amis pour finir je vous personne
remarque que j'y suis bon sens et c'est
beau mais si je suis juste là encore on
va dire de plus des villages et des
chevaux
je n'arrête les [ __ ] asthme pour la
fin de la vidéo allez-y allez-y comme ça
je finis comme ça
voilà j'en fais mon heure de gloire
merci à tous et à très vite pour le clip
we cotillard
[Musique]